hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to workout life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on done appear on the App Store or go
to fear live.com and start your journey
to become welcome to another beginner
workout
I'm Joanna so and today's workout is an
easy-to-follow indoor bootcamp workout
to work on your entire body if you have
just started in your fitness journey if
you're just starting to get active again
do this workout okay it's going to be
really easy really simple to follow 40
seconds of workout with 20 seconds rest
in between we will be going through your
total body so it will be trust exercises
in total all right so let's start with
warm-up okay so let's start by standing
shoulder-width apart again toes pointed
forward let's start with simple squat
okay as you squat down I want you to
push your butt back and raise your arms
up to the ceiling okay so you're
squatting as well as stretching on your
upper body good so push your butt back
and reach up I will be explaining each
move in detail very good keep going so
remember to push your butt back and
bring your arms both up at the same time
if you find that your toes are pointing
forward this is wrong okay so again push
your butt back and good keep going
two more give me one more last one
stretch chest up and back down now get
into a lunge position okay so step your
right leg forward and I want to bend
down and I again I want to just stretch
up
really push yourself back feel the
stretch on your lower back as well as
the hip flexor and now bring it back
down change side step bend your knees
and stretch back good let's do that few
more times step forward up and change if
you want to challenge yourself what you
can do is lift your knees off the floor
and back down switch sides again to
challenge yourself lift this knee off
the floor and reach back very good and
now in the same position I want you to
place one pant down and just twist and
look at the opposite side to challenge
yourself lift the resting knee and now
both pumps together bring your right leg
back left leg forward and twist and look
the opposite side good
feel the stretch a lot around your
glutes your inner thighs as well as your
thighs okay if this is too difficult
than what you can do is just rest your
knee on the floor one more on the other
side back choose your option okay good
and I'll just slowly stand up so just
relax just start by marching on the spot
remember that your goal throughout the
45 minutes of this workout is to break
your limits to push yourself but at the
same time I won
listen to your body hey so if this is
completely new no worries
take care your own pace and just follow
Allah so the first workout is going to
be step squat so what we want to do is
start by working on your lower body so
Stan showed up with a product who's
pointed forward do not point them out or
do not point that anyways okay so stare
should have width apart toes pointed
forward push your butt back squat and
now I want you to bring your left leg in
close together in a squat narrow squat
and back it down and now right leg out
and squat akin okay ready let's go
so shoulder-width apart let's go squat
down up narrow squat and now right
squat down up again back to narrow squat
and left good that's it very good so
narrow push your butt back up and good
again remember when you do a narrow
squat you will feel more on your glutes
okay very good so you might find that
this is more challenging and if you
can't go all the way down no where is it
just go halfway back up step wide go
deeper this time okay every time you
squat challenge yourself to go a little
deeper without hunching forward and now
just March and shake it out next it's
going to be a wide squat with tip toe
for this workout I want you to point
both toes out and get into a white
standing position okay so what I'm going
to do is squat down tap and as you come
up reach up and point your toes okay if
you can't point at us that's fine keep
your heels on the floor so tap up lift
your heels off and back again down reach
and lift your heels off remember it's
about squatting down it is not hunting
your body forward okay so squat down tap
up and tiptoe good down again and tiptoe
so squeeze on your calves right at the
top good back down up tiptoe squeeze in
the calves squat deep whew inner thighs
up again tiptoe remember step wide few
more last one more down
and just March and shake it out
push-ups do not worry we're not starting
with foo-foo shop so we're starting with
knee push-ups
so let's get down onto the mat okay get
onto your knees knees together and place
both palms on the mat slightly wider
than your shoulders and what a way to do
is bring your chest close down to the
floor and push yourself back up that's
it
so nice a controlled movement and push
yourself back up the most common mistake
is people doing this okay bringing their
head down to the floor or piping their
butt up this is drum so keep your body
in a straight line back down and push up
control back down and push up and
remember do not jerk or lock your knees
right at the top so control the movement
slowly control down push up feel your
chest squeeze your chest muscles to push
yourself up in a nice and controlled
manner one more up and relax shake it
out
next it's going to be a plank step in
and out this workout is going to work on
your core so get into a high plank
position
both palms on the floor toes slightly
wider if you want to or you can keep
them sugar with the pot find your option
okay so why don't you go the easier it
is so what I want to do is step out step
in out and in got that so left side out
bring them together right leg and bring
them together okay that's it left in
right and in so keep a nice high plank
without rocking your hips okay do not do
this this is strong solid plank tighten
your core look down and just step in and
out if you want to challenge yourself
then go faster speed it up a little bit
left and right step in and out good
that's it
in and out
and just relax check it out a little bit
next workout plank twists okay so again
in a high plank position but this time
we want to focus on your obliques so
let's get into a high plank position
step slightly wider to find your balance
what I'm going to do is twist and look
and reach the opposite side again back
down
look look up straighten your arm and
reach as high feel the stretch and back
down remember to maintain a solid plank
position if you're fine finding us of
doing this this is wrong okay so lower
your butt down tighten your core and
bring it back down good
tighten those ABS would work on your
core muscles and back down good spread
the pants wider to keep yourself
grounded to the floor reach twist reach
one more on the other side twist and how
does that feel okay this is good now
let's end with a little bit of cardio so
air jump rope what a way to do is
imagine you have a skipping rope in your
hand and just feel free to just hop side
to side one leg at a time you know or
both mix if you want it's up to you just
have fun okay and just rotate your wrist
slightly you can have both legs side to
side if you want to or just tap on your
heels have fun play with it we'll take
your waist move your hips and just have
fun and remember to swing your wrist as
well good keep going
double
out if you why to okay point double
side-to-side help side to side keep
going five more seconds just to bring
that hotter it up slightly alright
not much it out good next me side plank
okay so place both knees on the floor
stay on your elbows throughout the
workout all right what I want you to do
is place your arms around your waist
I want it to dip your hips close to the
floor lift it up squeeze your Blix bring
it back down lift it up and squeeze okay
so this is a very easy side knee plank
to start with good feel the squeeze in
your bricks remember to always keep your
body squared up and down good go up and
down if you find that do you know what I
want to challenge myself I want to break
my limits straighten both legs stack
them together lift it up bring it back
down up and back down okay
find your options remember to keep your
arms firmly grounded on the floor good
hah rest it out and now let's switch the
other side so choose your option okay
you can either stay on your knees if you
want to stay on both knees or stack both
feet on top of each other and raise your
hips up and down choose your option
alright let's go palms firmly on the
floor and up and down good keep going
you should really put the squeeze on the
outer thighs as well as your ways as
well as to work on your core to keep you
in balance if you feel that you're out
of balance then it's absolutely fine
your body and your muscles have to
remember the movements so the more you
do it
the better you will become added all
right keep going up and down up and down
squeeze show this push your shoulders
off the floor
few more last one and relax good now
let's lie on the floor let's get into a
breech match all right
so lie it down keep your knees up place
both feet on the floor and what I want
to do is lift your butt off the floor
into a high bridge position and I want
to do get into a marsh case so left leg
off right leg off and slowly get into a
March and your goal is not to drop your
hips okay so keep it up keep it high up
throughout the whole workout and drive
the knee close to your chest one at a
time
good keep going up up good there you go
squeeze it crunch it and feel it on your
lower abs as well it squeeze the gluts
work on the gluts and keep marching good
again like I always emphasize it's not
about rushing the workout but rather
it's filling the right muscles working
all right let's get up now let's get
into plank to downward dog okay so start
in a high plank and a way to push your
butt up into a downward dog so this is
also a really nice stretch to stretch on
your entire body you will feel it on
your upper back down through your spine
as well as your hand strength good so
thumbs firmly on the ground let's get
into a solid nice plank and now push
your butt up look in between your legs
through the stretch on your back down is
finally front
and now let's push it back again and
let's get your heels down onto the floor
okay so Pike your butt up as high as you
can back down into a plank and push it
if you can't get a Hughes on to the
floor that's fine slowly start by
pointing your heels down and get into a
walking dog as well okay this will
increase the flexibility on your
hamstring okay and now let's get into
Superman good so just face down okay
like flat down alright both arms point
it forward what I want to do is lift
your body up bring your arms back and
squeeze move back reach out and back
down let's go up bring your back squeeze
your back reach and back down so case
down squeeze your back as high as you
can and down good up squeeze reach good
there you go so you're working on your
lower back as well as your mid-back and
now find a workout before you get a
one-minute break let's get into another
cardio movement double knee okay so it's
really simple what I want to do is reach
double and then change side okay again I
want to get your heart rate up and you
will get a one-minute break after this
so let's go double knee tap and change
side tap
Lamoni switch site okay good if you can
reach as high as you can and tap your
thumbs to your knees all right let's go
for okay one two three good point
your legs back the other side one two
three four point and reach as high as
you can
good few more last one two three one
more side one two and rest it out take a
one-minute break keep yourself hydrated
we want to move on to the second run
wipe your sweat but I want you to keep
your energy level high up alright get
some water
my pink potion if you're wondering what
this is it's actually BCAA so the helps
with muscle recovery and it helps for me
to pull on my workout as well it just
gives me the extra energy please
especially if you have a long workout
session you should be stretchy okay
second round twenty seconds left
give me a best-effort and remember to
break your limits whatever you have done
in the first round add that intensity
push yourself even more and really sweat
it out all right let's go
step squat let's start with narrow squat
again remember to only go as far back as
you can without hunching forward okay so
left and right left and right and
challenge yourself to squat deeper every
time go deeper push your butt back even
lower and feel your glutes your
hamstrings and your quads working brace
your core look straight ahead
good
a few more one more whites one and shake
it out
okay now that we've worked on our glutes
our hamstrings now let's focus more on
our inner thighs so take a wide step and
let's work on wide squat with tiptoe
okay if it is too challenging you can't
find a balance then do it without
lifting your heels off so wide squat
toes pointed out ready
squat down have on the ball up tiptoe
good
squeeze your calves a few your cups
working down and reach up stretch it out
stretch and reach look as high as you
can
very nice down and up
good job keep going wide squat knees and
toes pointed out good feel your inner
thighs okay done again up good tap down
and reach push your butt back okay one
more check it out knee push up
remember do not pick a bar or do not
arch so keep both knees on the floor
palms slightly wider the shooter with
the pot keep the elbows pointed back
okay and now what I'm going to do is
bring your chest close to the floor and
usage has to push yourself back
let's go down and push us up back up
good flat back
three count how many pushups you can do
and the next time you repeat this workup
challenge yourself to do more push-ups
good keep going down okay
time yourself how many pushups can I do
in one minute let me know in the
comments below and then challenge
yourself keep working a pre-shop and you
will slowly increase the repetitions as
time goes by
one more
and planked step in and out right so
choose your option okay if you find that
you're struggling to do the step in and
out then just call a solid flag
okay so romantically remember to spread
your pumped white the wider you spread
upon the more foundation you will have
so both speak together that left in and
out alternating between legs
good nice plank position
okay flat back strong shoulders push
your arms into the ground and slowly
speed it up good there you go spit it up
last ten seconds okay go as far as you
can as fast as you can
white go wider reach and tap very nice
and I'll rest it out plank twists steer
in a plank position this time working
more on your balance as well as the
obliques okay just breathe in and
breathe out let's get into a high plank
feet wider than shoulder width apart and
now let's twist look up reach up back
down twist and look the opposite side
remember your goal is to always lengthen
your back just think long all right as
you reach up think lengthening your back
and reaching to the sky very good bring
it back down twist and reach
very good there you go
rotate your hips slightly and last one
and just shake it let's end with a
little bit of cardio okay so air jump
rope again have fun have fun imagine
you're a kid you have a skipping rope in
your head and just bounce it bounce it
off all right let's go 40 seconds
skipping good bouncing left and right
left and right side to side whatever
that you want to do just have fun with
it okay
double leg twist pointer toes pointed
heels shuffle if you want to or if this
is too harsh on your knees then just
March
okay choose your option but I wanted to
feel that your heart rate is going up
okay
last five seconds and rest let's get
back down on to their mat side plank
weather on your knees or on your toes
okay
beginners always start on your knees and
eventually as you progress stack your
feet together and get onto your toes all
right let's go up reach it up point up
down and up if you want to challenge
yourself even more then lift your arm up
and dip your hips down and up good if
this is too challenging place your arm
back onto your waist and just dip your
hips
down and up
good going last few more oh my god I can
feel it and switch the other side let's
go
typically you will find that one side
tend to be stronger than the other side
and usually it's always that your right
side is stronger than your left side
hence it is very important for us to
work on both sides in order to avoid
muscle imbalance okay so let's get up
and I'll dip down up down good which
slightly stronger let me know is that
your left or your right side which one
do you find that you can have better
balance down and up good again if you
want to challenge yourself raise one arm
straight up to the sky down up and down
good control okay do not just let your
hips drop control the movement and lift
it up squeeze it right at the top
squeeze and look straight ahead good and
now just relax let's lie down on the mat
let's do bridge March to work on your
glutes okay lie down keep your feet
shoulder width apart knees pointed up
feet firmly on the floor arms close to
your side
and now let's get into a bridge and
let's go left and right good
alternating between legs left and right
and remember your goal is to squeeze the
glutes and lift your body as high up as
you can imagine that's a string for your
bellybutton pulling you straight up okay
so do not dip your hips left and right
let's go keep going nice whoa
up and down and the last 10 seconds
let's speed it up slightly up knee to
chest March
very good I was there and relax right
swing yourself up let's get it to plank
to downward dog okay I love this stretch
it's a really good stretch at the same
time it works on your upper body and
core strength as well let's get into a
high plank okay feet shoulder-width
apart
let's go and push your butt back into
downward dog use onto the ground again
high plank push-up heels on the ground
look between your feet
creating a high mountain up good spread
your fingers very good keep going
nice solid plank one more and just relax
shake it out a little bit alright shake
it off now let's lie down on the mat
with your face facing the mat okay
remember to keep your neck in a neutral
position throughout let's do Superman to
work on your lower as well as a mid-back
arms straight let's go up three back
squeeze it
release and down squeeze
pristine and out cute control your
breathing listen to your body
fewer muscles lift as high up as I can
squeeze the glutes the low back and
slowly go back into the starting
position squeeze
right let's get up to n the second round
another card here okay now let's do knee
twist so what I want to do is keep both
arms close to your head and I want to
just twist the opposite side that's it
it is simple as that but you'll be
working on your car okay so let's go
twist twist some of you might find this
challenging and you feel that you can't
reach your knee to your elbow that it's
absolutely fine just go as far as you
can and just reach good keep going
twist point and twist good work on that
Bleek's very good so this is a good core
workout without crunches we can get our
whole workout done
but without crunching so you can do core
exercises standing up as well keep going
keep twisting twist few more five more
seconds and you get a one-minute break
twist that's one and shake it out well
done very well done
two rounds down one more round to go
take this precious one minute to keep
yourself hydrated what your sweat and we
want to repeat all the troph
exercises again all right do not stop
this video right now let's do this and
let's end this workout together
it's only a 45-minute workout so I like
to either get this workout done first
thing in the morning before you start
your day and it will give you a boost of
energy or do you know what if you find
that my sketches to time I can't fit in
a morning workout that's absolutely fine
get this workout done once you're back
in the evening there is no perfect
timing to do a workout but it's most
important is that you keep your workout
consistent no matter what time of the
day right step squat in ten seconds okay
so let's start with narrow squat and
let's go on our left and on our right
that's sad
push yourself squat deeper let's go down
stop good
in and out there you go nice go back
down and squat okay
very good this is a low-impact workout
so this work is great for everybody no
jumping and shake it out okay next
workout you know the drill wide squat
okay so step wide toes pointed out if
you want to challenge yourself going
even wider this time okay go even wider
find that balance and that's dig deep
ready let's go
squat touch down reach up squeeze your
calves as you lift your heels off the
floor down and up and up good reach up
whoo up nice remember do not hunch
forward okay this is wrong
squat down your goal is to get your fat
as low as you can
good tiptoe and squeeze across one count
and go back down more you got one more
knee push-ups let's work on our upper
body okay nobody a lot lower body
muscles are bigger other body muscles
are smaller
hence it is tougher but it doesn't mean
we should not work on a lob avoid
strength so shoot it with a pop slightly
wider let's go nice on the floor and go
back down push it up down and up okay if
this is too challenging
then just do small pulses to begin with
as you progress go deeper and push up
down and up good
down and up back down and up guys if you
find that you know what I can't even do
knee push-ups boy can do is start on the
wall okay so get onto the wall find a
wall step about two feet away and spread
it on slightly wider there shut it with
a pot and reach close to the wall and
push yourself okay that's another great
option to start doing push-ups if needs
to challenging get onto the wall next
plank step in and out again if the plank
challenging you can't do it that's fine
get on your knees okay give me a nice
flat back step in reach in step in and
reach out good that's it okay this is a
beginner option most important is that
you get a workout done and you start
somewhere everybody needs a starting
point so do not feel disappointed if you
can't get into a full plank just yet as
you progress get into a plank step in
and out good there you go nobody gets
fit overnight it takes months and years
of consistency and dedication all right
so don't compare yourself to anybody
else compare yourself to yourself only
it's important to track you your
progress as well just relax
the next plank twist again if you can't
get into a full plank stop in your knees
twist to the side back down and twist
okay find your option right let's get
into a high plank and let's go pine
twist reach back down and reach good
feel the stretch
keep going
through the rotation work on your
mobility as well very nice okay spread
your legs slightly wider wider you
spread your legs the easier the work on
becomes as you progress bring your legs
closer together one more back down all
right have fun
Eric jump rope imagine you have a
skipping rope in your hand
have fun hop left right front back
everywhere you want you can even bring
your knees up okay this is your cardio
workout to end the first circuit and we
want to move on to the remaining six
workout so spot gentle you can even
bring your knees out if you want to push
yourself okay tap
or one lick you can always do one leg
hop change fight hop side to side
everyone's in it not change side double
leg hop
okay hope front and back rest let's get
down onto plank side plank okay right
come with their second exercises and you
are done
45 minutes solid workout okay hunts on
the net
let's get up
dip and go back up good
very good bring your hips as close to
the floor as you can and lift it up
before it touches to the floor down and
up down and up it looks straight ahead
or
keep going done it up
when the balance Singapore
last one and change let's go on the
other side oh I am sweating but if
you're so good okay ready
in seven seconds catch your breath
breathe in breathe out
oh no let's challenge yourself okay get
onto your toes
everybody get onto your toes challenge
yourself even if you can only last for
20 seconds it doesn't matter challenge
yourself up and down keep going
very good you only have 20 seconds left
keep going feel your arms shaking
phew your entire body shaking that is
absolutely fine you're doing great and
keep going ten more seconds push it up
back down up control down back up that's
one up down and now just relax alright
lie on the mat breech March okay again
toes point to forward feet firmly on the
ground arms by your side
ready lift your body up and now let's
march up and down aim to bring your knee
as high as you can
close your chest without tipping your
hips up and down okay aim to bring your
knee as close to your chest as possible
good lift your entire body up you should
only be your shoulders touching the mat
keep going last five seconds
let's go speed it up slightly and relax
good let's get up to plank and downward
dog
okay I love this stretch I really like
this stretch even right at the end of my
workout I like to do this stretch
alright so let's get into a plank high
plank ready and now let's push your butt
up into downward dog and try to get your
huge down onto the floor okay try your
best and back into a plank and up so
when you're in a plank your palms arms
and shoulders should be in a straight
line push back feel the stretch on your
entire back down your spine and your
hamstrings into a nice plank gaze down
and push back look between your legs
cues on the floor plank again stretch it
out a few more
and just relax Superman okay so no lie
flat down on the net again remember to
keep your neck in a neutral position so
do not look or exert your neck look
straight down reach out and lick your
body up squeeze a little back squeeze
your mid-back and back down up as high
as you can okay so challenge yourself as
high as you can look up and now look
down
good that's how you can lift your legs
off the floor squeeze your glutes
squeeze those glutes good there you go
and back down
whoo last to work out and we have one
more card a blaster and all right for
this final cardio blast I wanted to do a
sidestep with a touchdown okay so this
is going to really work on your legs so
start in the middle find your space get
a little bit of extra space on your left
and right all right get a loan keep
yourself low double step touch
double step and tap okay good the lower
you keep your body the more challenging
it will be okay you will incorporate a
lot more lower body muscles good step
down reach tap and tap good again keep
your chest up okay do not compromise on
your floor tap few more if you want to
speed it up last workout okay last
workout spin it up last ten seconds as
far as I can double stab push yourself
oh that's me more last one one more huh
well done you did 45 minutes indoor boot
camp workout so your hair should be
messy like mine your heart rate should
be pumping you should be sweating and
you should feel damn good if you enjoyed
this workout if you want more live
classes be sure to check out my fitness
app feel on the app store or go to fear
live.com we'll be sharing a daily life
workout classes with other amazing top
trainers and trust me you do not want to
miss any workouts if you like this
workout be sure to give this video a
thumbs up subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more work up videos
work at challenges healthy recipes and I
will be guiding you through your fitness
journey so do this workout consistent
and
three to four times weekly on alternate
days and trust me you will see results
to only get stronger and you will start
to lose weight all the best